Let's talk about jobs and unemployment.
A little bit today, there are lies.
There is ignorance.
There is bad faith argumentation.
And then there's combining all three to weaponize
them against your political opponents when
you know that your followers will believe
any dumb thing that you tell them.
And Donald Trump is now claiming that his
his daughter, Ivanka.
This is so insane.
Who has no formal role with the administration,
has single handedly created 15 million jobs
herself.
Now, question one is she has no role with
the administration.
How exactly is she creating jobs?
Never mind.
15 million jobs.
Let's table that question for now so that
we avoid crying.
Let's go to the video right away.
And then I will discuss it.
Donna Evocca Trump who just wants to have
people working.
That's why I gave her lots of options.
And what do you like?
And she created over 15 million jobs working
with some of you, but working with the biggest
companies in the world.
They were training and training.
Like nobody's ever seen.
But she started off with a goal of five hundred
thousand jobs and now she's up to over 15
million.
So there are tons of Trump ists who will see
this video and they're going to believe it.
Now, let's just do the math on it.
The U.S. population is estimated right now
to be 331 million.
Let's call it three hundred and thirty million
people.
A rough estimate of the number of people working
in the U.S. in 2020 prior to the virus.
Remember, since the virus has started, more
than 16 million people have filed for unemployment.
An even bigger number have lost their jobs.
But before the virus, we had 158 million people
working in the U.S. Trump says a Vanko created
15 million jobs.
If if Bonga created 15 million jobs, that
is 10 percent of all the jobs in the United
States.
Can you imagine a more obviously false assertion
than the idea that Trump's daughter, who has
no official position in the White House and
has essentially done nothing, created 10 percent
of the jobs in the United States?
But let's take it a step further.
Even if you ignore that, obviously, 10 percent
of American jobs couldn't possibly have been
created right by Ivana Trump.
The entire American economy prior to Corona
virus had added only six point six point two
million jobs, period.
So Donald Trump is arguing that his daughter
created eight million jobs above and beyond
all jobs that are known to have been created
during the Trump administration.
Now, you might hear this and say, obviously,
nobody is going to believe that.
And you would be very, very wrong.
Search Twitter, search the Trump list on claims
of the Internet.
And you will realize that this has already
become a talking point that people are using
to prop up a vanga.
Why so many? Trump is through definite def
desperate to prop up Ivanka right now.
I really couldn't tell you.
It is a talking point that they are using
relentlessly, apparently applying zero critical
thinking skills to the claim.
Or maybe some of them are realizing that it's
a lie, but repeating the lie anyway.
It genuinely seems that Donald Trump doesn't
understand numbers, just simple numbers, or
he's just lying.
And when it comes to Trump's relationship
with Ivanka, you know, I hope this is not
off color, off color to mentioned.
But Trump's the same guy who has previously
called his daughter voluptuous.
Trump's the same guy who has previously said
his daughter is someone that he would love
to be dating if she wasn't his daughter.
So maybe there is more here.
Maybe it's just Trump says really strange
things about a banka in general.
And they could be economic or they could be
about other things.
But this is such an obvious lie and it's particularly
sinister.
Now, when we have lost sixteen point eight
million jobs minimum, the real number is higher
because not everybody's filed for unemployment.
Who has lost their job?
We have lost more than 16 million jobs in
three weeks due to the virus.
And Trump is sitting around bragging about
his daughter supposedly creating 10 percent
of all jobs in the American economy.
Incredible.
And people are falling for it